and the silver medal award this year
will go to director Rachel Gordon lobe
for her film every Tuesday a portrait of
The New Yorker cartoonists Rachel well
hello um I want to thank the Academy so
very much for this honor and for this
week it's been a pleasure just an
unbelievable pleasure for me and I want
to thank my family my parents and my
brother for their love and support and
my friends who act as my creative just
constantly I am able to talk with them
and check in with them about my projects
and their projects and I'd like to thank
my SBA classmates for all of their help
and support and my teachers and Collins
Michelle Negroponte and Jeremiah's agar
for their encouragement and support
throughout this time at school and after
and I'd also like to thank my elementary
school video and TV teacher Miss Susan
michael who starting in kindergarten I
was getting to make videos with her and
so I just want to thank all of them and
thank you again Academy for this
wonderful honor